nos preguntan cuál es el valor
posicional de 3 en el número 654 punto 2
1 3 para que entendamos estos déjenme
reescribir el número pero con distintos
colores
tenemos 6
4 nuestro punto decimal
vamos a analizar cada cifra con su valor
posicional para que podamos tener la
respuesta adecuada
tomaré un color neutro
este 6 se encuentra tres lugares hacia
la izquierda del punto decimal este 6
está en las centenas
o lo que es lo mismo 10 al cuadrado o
segunda potencia este 5 está en el lugar
de las decenas
o lo que es lo mismo 10 a la primera
potencia
y este 4 está en las unidades
unidades lo que es lo mismo que 10 a la
0 potencia y esto ya es un tanto
familiar para nosotros vamos a entrar en
el terreno de los decimales este 2 que
es el primero que se encuentra a la
derecha del punto decimal está en la
posición de las décimas un décimo o diez
a la menos uno tenemos este uno en la
posición de los centésimos
10 a la menos 2 y finalmente tenemos
este 3 en el lugar de los miles y mos
o 10 al menos 3
si nos preguntan cuál es el valor
posicional de 3 realmente estaríamos
diciendo que el valor posicional son los
milésimos y eso sería nuestra respuesta
sin embargo me gustaría que analizáramos
esto un poco más para que entendamos
porque el valor posicional son las
milésimas
si reescribimos este mismo número
tendremos que es 600
más
este 5 nos representa 50
+ 4 unidades será 4 unidades más
dos décimas
decimos
un centésimo
milésimos
y en términos de multiplicaciones vamos
a saber cómo es que se representa este
número es decir aquí tenemos 600 sí
porque es un 6 que se encuentra en el
valor posicional de las centenas
6% es igual a 600 más
5 que se encuentran un 5 que se
encuentra multiplicándose por las
decenas cinco decenas cinco por diez es
igual a 50
4 que es un 4 que se está multiplicando
por unidades 4 por 14 unidades más
2 este 2 nos representa que se está
multiplicando por un décimo
dos décimos es igual a dos
multiplicándose por un décimo
+ 11 que se está multiplicando por un
centésimo
y finalmente
un 3 que se está multiplicando por
milésimos por un milésimo así es que
aquí tenemos cuál es el valor posicional
de 3 el 3 está en el valor de los miles
decimos como lo indica vamos arriba en
resumen si nos recorremos hacia la
izquierda del punto tenemos 6 centenas
6% cinco decenas 5 por 10 4 unidades 4
por 1
y 3 que está siendo multiplicado por un
milésimo nos vemos en otro vídeo